how does it begin to get good at Jiu
Jitsu like given that you're starting
this white bow what's your philosophy on
that obviously you buy all of my
instructionals yeah at full price yeah
not during a sale okay that would go a
long way for those of you who are
Russians I'll give you I'll send you
instructions for all the forms so you
know how to how to steal it yeah sure I
bought them all so I'll just send it to
you we do I mean we do have the Maca
show 50 discount code you know yeah
offering discounts to help him out for
the rematch I got the nice
picture
uh well I got a 100 discount for you if
you need it but that says you're
instructional are both hilarious and
Brilliant and it's one of the most
respective instructionals oh thank you
with incredibly great names yeah it
probably loses me sales honestly due to
removing the seriousness is gonna kind
of suck it's gonna be some funny
um gimmicky thing or I mean some people
don't even know if it's a real product
that's a big hurdle after overcome is
they see it and they're like is that a
real thing that's a problem but how does
the Wipeout get good I think they just I
mean just have to show up you just have
to put in the effort uh try to focus on
using techniques and training rather
than just fighting to the death you know
although that is entertaining for us to
watch to wipers fight at the death yeah
but what are the techniques you should
focus on like what's the process what
does it mean to show up like how much
drilling all that kind of stuff like
what if you were to optimize the first
six months of a of a beginner there's a
lot of people would listen to this and
haven't tried they've been curious I
have a lot of friends who haven't who
are like you're just too curious they're
constantly looking Fern excuse to start
I think it's just got to be as simple as
possible you know like we shouldn't be
teaching more advanced movements I mean
obviously in the grand schema thinks
this highly Advanced Techniques and then
they're slightly Advanced and I think
trying to teach those guys real specific
positions even like real specific types
of God it's just beyond them I think the
best way to learn is through problem
solving and I think if you show the
technique before they've discovered that
problem
the learning is sort of held back so I
like the idea of using kids style games
to show them a problem and then use the
techniques to fix the problems they've
just discovered I think that's the best
way to learn can you give an example of
a problem to show them before you give
them the techniques like what are we
talking about all right so say you
wanted to teach uh posture in wrestling
you could create a game where one guy
the game might be get to a leg or get to
two legs control the leg like super
simple but the rules the constraint
would be one guy is forced to keep
upright posture and one guy is forced
will not force but he's allowed to keep
a bent at the hips lower posture and
obviously within the that constraint the
guy with the better posture is going to
have more success he's gonna have a
better posture to secure a leg or secure
both legs and therefore you've
demonstrated the flaws of bad posture
without having to explain it to him
before they really tested that out okay
and then the result of that you would
realize that the the bent over posture
is better yeah you have that aha moment
rather than just being having it spoken
to you
uh you wrote Craig I'm a big fan of
constraint based learning I guess was
just what you're talking about I love
presenting beginners with a problem
before the solution like here attempt to
hold side control with no with no cues
on how then I see how the guy
got out and addressed issue by issue
cross face and hip control and so on
okay so what are some other examples
like side control yeah that would be
excellent one side control like teacher
like obviously we say oh you secure a
crossfire so they can't turn into you
much easier to have them try to hold
someone down without explaining what a
cross face is and then use that
technique to address the problem they've
just encountered so I think you could do
that with a lot of areas of Jiu Jitsu
like even more advanced say 50 50.
obviously a mirrored position where you
both have access to each other's heels
most people stole that in that position
and keep their feet crossed I think a
great constraint for both of them you
can't cross your feet now you have to
learn how to uh slip the heel hook when
they expose it and how to safely
re-attack of your own so the constraint
is you can't be too defensive in that
position and I think the learn the rate
of learning increases why do you think
the rate of learning increases like what
do you think that works because you
encounter more problems say in that
situation they're going to get you heal
a lot more in whatever period of time
you allocate the drill for then if the
legs across I don't think the hard
part's splitting the legs to get to the
submission I think the hard part's
practicing control while they're trying
to slip it out later stage and then
obviously trying to slip your Hill when
you're in more danger also makes you
more comfortable in that bad position if
you're used to doing it with open legs
yeah I think that probably that style of
teaching forces people to focus on
because it's so easy to fall into
focusing on like memorizing a particular
details of a technique without thinking
like where the hell does this even work
and if you don't have that you could get
to focus on like from like as cliche as
it sounds from first principles like why
the hell
how the hell do I get out of this like
why does this even work why does
wrestling work why do you have a bent
over posture you get those like start to
ask those kinds of questions which is
kind of interesting because it's not
obvious to me that bent over posture is
the right posture for jiu jitsu right
I'm confused actually about that I don't
know about the correct posture yeah for
jiu jitsu like what's the right answer
I think van ever post is still good for
Jiu-Jitsu even with the Judo and all
that like why are so many Jiu Jitsu
people like at a high level the posture
is higher up
well I think the I think wrestling
posture is just a bit too low because
it's not necessary right if wrestlers
are like low enough to the ground where
your hands can touch the mat uh but in
Jiu Jitsu you know it's a it's kind of a
mix between like wrestling and like uh
Judo or or Greco-Roman wrestling so
um I think it's just a bit more more
relaxed and it's it's bent over but it's
not upright and it's also not super low
you know a bit more room for attitude
because obviously the uh Jiu Jitsu guy
shot isn't going to be as athletic as
quick as a wrestlers especially the rest
of the shoes so it actually comes down
to the fact that Jiu Jitsu people just
on average even at the top level are not
good at shooting
I think so yeah I think obviously I mean
all the Restless in American stuff
they're starting super early super young
you know what I mean they're they've by
the time they get to the same age we are
really uh announceable and stuff they've
spent much longer doing the actual sport
and the average jujitsu